qué significa momento bueno el momentum
se define como la masa por la velocidad
y lo puedes ver aquí el momento es la
masa por la velocidad y por qué nos
importa el momento bueno porque si
tenemos un sistema que no tiene una
fuerza externa neta en ese sistema
entonces el momento se conservará en
otras palabras si nos fijamos en el
momento total que tenemos inicialmente
bueno pues éste va a ser igual al
momento total que tengamos al final así
que el momento será conservativo si no
hay fuerzas externas netas y bueno el
momentum es un vector lo que significa
que tiene componentes el momento total
se dirigirá en dirección de la velocidad
total que es esta de aquí pero el
momento en cada dirección pueden o no
conservarse
en otras palabras si no hay una fuerza
neta en la dirección x eso quiere decir
que el momento en dirección x será
conservativo y de igual manera si vemos
que no hay una fuerza neta en dirección
jeff eso va a decir que el momento en
dirección que basel conservativa y ya
que el momento es mvc
entonces las unidades van a ser
kilogramos por metros sobre segundos así
que como se ve un problema que involucra
el momento dos bloques de masas 3 m y m
se dirigen uno hacia el otro
deslizándose sobre una superficie sin
fricción con velocidades de 225 ver
respectivamente y permanecen juntas en
qué dirección las dos masas se
deslizarán a través del suelo sin
fricción recuerdan el suelo no tenía
fricción
pues de la colisión muy bien para
averiguarlo podemos preguntarnos
inicialmente en qué dirección está el
momento total del sistema y como el
momento va a ser conservativo s tendrá
que estar en la dirección del momento
final así que veamos qué es lo que pasa
con este de aquí y este equipo tiene un
momento de 3 m vamos a multiplicar su
masa por su velocidad que es 2 b
entonces en este caso el momento de este
primer bloque va a ser de 6 veces
mb muy bien ahora fijémonos qué es lo
que pasa con este segundo bloque este
segundo bloque tiene como masa a m y lo
vamos a multiplicar por su velocidad
pero no olvides que esta velocidad va a
ser negativa recuerdan que es negativa
porque va en dirección contraria y como
el momento es un vector no puedes
olvidar los signos negativos por lo
tanto vas a tener esta masa multiplicada
por menos 5 pm lo cual nos va a dar un
momento de menos 5 veces me ven muy bien
así que el momento inicial del sistema
este de aquí va a ser igual a más 6 mb
más menos 5 mb lo cual me dan m b m de
positivo eso quiere decir que el momento
inicialmente está hacia la derecha lo
que significa que después de la colisión
el momento también debe de estar hacia
la derecha y la única forma en la que
eso puede suceder es si estas dos masas
están unidas es decir si el total de la
masa combinada también se mueve hacia la
derecha
impulsó el impulso es igual a la
cantidad de fuerza ejercida en el objeto
o en el sistema multiplicado por el
tiempo durante el cual la fuerza ha
actuado y lo podemos ver justo aquí si
nos fijamos en el impulso es lo mismo
que la fuerza que multiplica a una
diferencia de tiempo es decir el tiempo
durante el cual se ha aplicado esta
fuerza y también lo podemos ver por acá
si nos fijamos el impulso neto va a ser
igual a la fuerza neta que aplicamos
durante un cierto periodo de tiempo y
esto también va a ser el cambio en el
momento de ese sistema o de ese objeto
en otras palabras si esta masa tiene un
momento inicial y bueno termina con un
cierto momento final entonces puedo
decir que el cambio en el momento de
esta masa el cambio en el momento de
esta masa es decir el momento final
menos el momento inicial va a ser lo
mismo que él
pulso neto que por cierto esto va a ser
lo mismo que la fuerza neta que se va a
aplicar a esta masa que multiplica al
cambio en el tiempo en el cual aplicamos
esta fuerza y bueno como el impulso es
un cambio en el momento y el momento es
un vector entonces podemos decir que el
impulso también es un vector así que
puede ser positivo o negativo y las
unidades son las mismas que el momento
las cuales son kilogramos por metro
sobre segundo también lo podemos ver la
siguiente manera lo podemos ver como una
fuerza por un cierto tiempo por lo tanto
también pueden ser newtons por segundo y
si quieres ver un problema que involucra
el impulso entonces podemos ver el
siguiente pregunta de ejemplo una pelota
de masa m está moviéndose inicialmente a
la derecha hace un muro con una
velocidad de 2 ve cómo se ve a
continuación aquí lo tenemos la pelota
retrocede del muro con una velocidad
esto es importante cuál es la magnitud
del impulso en la pelota de parte del
muro
bueno pues recordemos que el impulso es
exactamente lo mismo que el cambio en el
momento y esto va a ser igual al momento
final al momento final menos el momento
inicial así que esto va a ser igual y
primero vamos a fijarnos en el momento
final que es lo que pasa justo aquí el
momento final se observa va a ser igual
a la masa la cual es m por la velocidad
pero la velocidad va hacia la izquierda
va en contra de la velocidad inicial por
lo tanto tiene un signo negativo eso
quiere decir que el momento final va a
ser igual de menos
mb recuerda hay que tener cuidado con
los signos entonces aquí me va a quedar
menos mb ya esto habrá que quitarle el
momento inicial así que vamos a fijarnos
qué es lo que pasa aquí y si observas es
la masa por la velocidad la velocidad es
positiva y me va a quedar
a veces me ven entonces puedo decir que
el impulso va a ser igual a menos tres
veces
mp eso quiere decir que el impulso neto
va a dirigirse a la misma dirección que
la fuerza neta en este caso este muro
ejerce una fuerza hacia la izquierda por
eso tenemos este signo negativo y el
impulso también tienen este signo
negativo y tenemos una magnitud de 3 mb
así que mi respuesta es 3 mb ahora si
ves el impulso como el área en la
gráfica de puesta contratiempo la
primera cosa que deberías de pensar es
que el área debajo de esta gráfica será
igual al impulso sobre el objeto así que
si gráficas la fuerza de algún objeto
como una función del tiempo como tenemos
justo aquí el área bajo la curva será
igual al impulso solo que ten cuidado ya
que el área bajo la curva por arriba del
eje del tiempo
un impulso positivo positivo ya que si
nos fijamos en el área que está entre el
eje del tiempo y la función fuerza y
estamos por abajo del eje del tiempo
entonces vamos a tener un impulso
negativo porque observa que nos estamos
tomando una fuerza negativa y si te
preguntas por qué nos interesa ver al
área bajo la curva como el impulso la
respuesta es porque si podemos encontrar
el área esto va a ser igual al impulso y
si podemos encontrar el impulso neto en
un objeto eso también nos dará el cambio
en el momento de ese objeto lo que
significa que podríamos averiguar el
cambio de la velocidad en un objeto y si
ahora te preguntas cómo se ve un
problema que involucra el impulso visto
como el área bajo la curva o un cohete
de juguete de 2 kilogramos de masa se
dirigen inicialmente a la derecha con
una velocidad de 10 metros sobre segundo
sé que es una fuerza en dirección
horizontal sobre él
como se muestran en la siguiente gráfica
cuál es la velocidad del cohete en el
instante de tema igual a 10 segundos es
decir justo en este instante de aquí
para resolverlo vamos a averiguar el
área bajo la curva así que me voy a
aplicar en el área bajo la curva que
tenemos justo aquí esta que tenemos aquí
la cual recuerda va a contar como área
positiva y si nos fijamos por acá en
este otro triángulo vamos a observar que
esta área de clint va a contar como
negativa así que esta de aquí es
positiva esta área es negativa por lo
tanto se anulan entre sí y la única área
de la que debemos preocuparnos es el
área entre los 8 y los 10 segundos y
esto va a terminar siendo un área
negativa ya que la altura de este
rectángulo que tengo aquí es
-30 nos lo dicen justo aquí por otra
parte el ancho de este rectángulo es de
2 segundos y entonces esto nos va a dar
un impulso de menos 60 newton segundos
así que si el impulso
es de menos 60 newtons por segundo eso
va a ser exactamente lo mismo que el
cambio en el momento lo cual es igual al
momento final
- el momentum inicial
ahora bien podemos calcular cuánto es el
momento inicial el momento inicial va a
ser igual a la masa que es 2 kilogramos
nos lo dicen justo aquí que multiplican
a la velocidad final que es 10 metros
sobre segundo que multiplica a 10 metros
sobre segundo es decir el momento
inicial va a ser igual a 20 kilogramos
metros sobre segundo así que si usamos
esta información me va a quedar que
menos 60 newtons por segundo es igual al
momento final menos 20 20 a la velocidad
final
y si de aquí despejamos el momento final
voy a llegar que el momento final va a
ser igual a menos 60 newtons por segundo
más 20 kilogramos metros sobre segundo
lo cual es lo mismo que menos 40
kilogramos metros sobre segundo ahora
vienen para encontrar la velocidad final
esta va a ser igual a esta cantidad que
tengo aquí menos 40 kilogramos metros
sobre segundo y lo vamos a dividir entre
la masa la masa eran 2 kilogramos así
que los kilogramos se eliminan y me va a
quedar menos menos 20 metros sobre
segundo eso nos da la respuesta correcta
ahora bien cuál es la diferencia entre
una colisión elástica y una inelástica
bueno que si tenemos una colisión
elástica entonces la energía cinética
total se conserva
eso durante la colisión es decir que si
tenemos la colisión de una esfera con un
cubo y nos fijamos en la energía que
tiene la esfera y a eso le sumamos la
energía cinética del cubo entonces esto
tiene que ser igual a la energía
cinética que tiene la esfera más la
energía cinética que tiene el cubo pero
después de la colisión es decir la
energía cinética total se conserva la
suma de las energías iniciales tiene que
ser igual a la suma de las energías
finales eso en una colisión elástica ojo
ten cuidado no es suficiente que los dos
objetos reboten entre sí si los dos
objetos rebotan la energía cinética
podría no conservarse solamente cuando
la energía cinética se conserva es que
hablamos de una colisión
en el otro caso para una colisión
inelástica la energía cinética no se
conserva en otras palabras la energía
cinética inicial del sistema no es igual
a la energía cinética final del sistema
y qué pasa con esa energía en la mayoría
de los casos se convierte en energía
térmica bien las masas pueden rebotar
durante la colisión en elástica pero si
permanecen juntas en el momento del
choque si permanecen juntas entonces
hablamos de una colisión inelástica
perfecta y es que esta colisión va a
transformar la mayor energía cinética en
energía térmica cuando dos objetos
permanecen juntos es una señal segura de
que esta colisión es definitivamente
inelástica ahora cómo se ve un problema
que involucre colisiones sin elásticas y
elásticas dos bloques de masa 2 m
james se dirigen uno hacia el otro
deslizándose sobre una superficie sin
fricción con velocidades de 4 2 y 6 ver
respectiva
después de la colisión el de masa 2 m
está en reposo y el de masa m tiene una
velocidad de 220 hacia la derecha la
colisión fue elástica o inelástica ahora
es posible que rápidamente que es decir
que estos dos objetos rebotan entre sí y
por lo tanto hablamos de una colisión
elástica pero ten cuidado eso no
forzosamente es cierto si la colisión es
elástica entonces los dos objetos van a
rebotar pero ojo que los objetos reboten
no significan que la colisión es
elástica en otras palabras rebotar es
una condición necesaria pero no
suficiente para que la colisión sea el
astica si realmente quieres saber si la
colisión fue elástica debes determinar
la energía cinética total se conservó o
no se conservó la velocidad de esta masa
de 2 m
lo que quiere decir que la energía está
bajando pero no sólo eso también la
velocidad de la masa m está bajando eso
quiere decir que la energía también está
bajando en esta masa de m así que la
energía cinética de ambas masas bajan
entonces la energía cinética final va a
ser menor que la energía cinética
inicial lo que significa que como la
energía cinética no se conserva la
colisión tiene que ser inelástica ojo y
ten cuidado porque aunque la energía
cinética no se conserva el momento
inicial es igual al momento final lo que
quiere decir que el momento si se está
conservando de hecho el momento se
conserva para ambos tipos de colisiones
para la colisión elástica y para la
colisión inelástica en lo que nos
tenemos que fijar es en la energía
cinética y si la energía estética no se
conservan estamos hablando de una
colisión inelástica bien ahora como
trabajas con colisiones en 2d bueno el
momento será conservado para cada
dirección en la que no hay
neto eso quiere decir que si no hay un
pulso neto en ambas direcciones entonces
el momento en ambas direcciones se
conserva en otras palabras si no hay una
fuerza neta externa en dirección x
entonces el momento total x se va a
conservar será constante y de igual
manera si no hay una fuerza neta externa
en dirección james entonces el momento
en la dirección james se va a conservar
y lo podemos ver aquí si empezamos con
la colisión de dos partículas y vemos
que el momento inicial en dirección x en
estas dos esferas se conservan eso
quiere decir que al final el momento en
esas dos direcciones este más este debe
de ser igual al momento inicial al
momento con el que empezamos esto si no
hay un impulso neto en esa dirección y
de igual manera si nos fijamos en el
momento en dirección james
en este caso no hay se va a conservar
sin la suma de los dos momentos en james
es exactamente igual al momento en que
me inicial si la suma de estos dos se
conservan y claro esto si no hay un
impulso neto en esta dirección y ahora
como se ve un problema de todo esto una
esfera de metal de más am emen está
viajando horizontalmente con una
velocidad de 5 metros sobre segundo
cuando colisiona con una esfera idéntica
de masa m pero que estaba en reposo
después de la colisión la esfera
original tiene componentes de velocidad
v de x 4 metros sobre segundo de de
james tres metros sobre segundo cuáles
son los componentes de velocidad de la
otra esfera después de la colisión lo
que vamos a suponer es que no hay
fuerzas externas netas en las
direcciones x hoy m
entonces el momento se va a conservar
para cada dirección ahora bien ya que la
masa es la misma para estos dos
es la misma esto quiere decir que
podemos fijarnos en las componentes de
la velocidad original ya que si
iniciamos con una velocidad en x de 5
metros sobre segundo tenemos que
terminar también con una velocidad en x
de 5 metros sobre ese punto por lo tanto
aquí tenemos que tener un metro sobre
segundo muy bien y de igual manera para
la velocidad en la componente y james
como empezamos el momento en la
dirección vertical
debemos terminar ese momento en
dirección vertical así que la primera
esfera tiene tres unidades de momento
verticalmente después de la colisión eso
significa que la segunda esfera debe de
tener tres unidades de momento
verticalmente pero hacia abajo esto
después de la colisión y entonces si nos
fijamos vemos que la opción correcta es
la de que es el centro de masa el centro
de masa de un objeto sistema es el punto
donde el objeto se equilibra el centro
de masa también es el punto sobre el
cual actual la gravedad y bueno se puede
calcular con ésta
fórmula que tengo aquí en la cual vamos
a multiplicar la masa por el
desplazamiento por la distancia que hay
de la masa desde el punto x igual a cero
nuestro punto de referencia y si no
tienes ese punto de referencia es
importante que tú lo establezcas porque
a partir de ahí va a ser el punto en
donde x sea igual a cero no está para
posiciones a la izquierda del punto de
referencia éstas contarán como
posiciones negativas ahora bien cuando
termines de calcular toda esta suma de
la masa por las distancias que hay al
punto de referencia vas a dividir todo
esto entre la masa total que simplemente
es la suma de todas las masas y esto nos
va a dar un número ese número es el
centro de masa y el centro de masa
tendrá unidades de metros
eso es muy importante ya que es una
ubicación la ubicación donde el sistema
u objeto se equilibrarían y la ubicación
donde todo el centro de gravedad está
actuando por eso aquí dicen que es el
punto donde actúa la gravedad además es
muy importante recordar que el centro de
masa no se va a acelerar excepto que
haya una fuerza externa en el sistema en
otras palabras el centro de masa de un
sistema siempre obedece la primera ley
de newton es decir que si el centro de
masa estuviera por aquí vamos a ponerlo
este es mi centro de masa este centro de
masa va a seguir aquí aunque estas masas
se estén moviendo aunque hayan fuerzas
en estas masas entre sí el centro de
masa va a permanecer en el mismo sitio
excepto que haya una fuerza externa una
fuerza externa que mueva a este centro
de masa y si el centro de masa estuviera
inicialmente moviéndose hacia alguna
hogar supongamos que este centro de masa
se está moviendo con una cierta
velocidad hacia la derecha va a
mantenerse moviendo con esa velocidad a
la derecha incluso si las masas se están
moviendo en diferentes direcciones hasta
que haya una fuerza externa neta y bueno
como se ve un problema que involucra el
centro de masa un auto de control remoto
de masa m está colocado en reposo en una
tabla de madera de masa m en la posición
que se muestra a continuación en esta
posición que tengo aquí aquí está mi
auto muy bien después dice hay fricción
entre el auto y la tabla pero no entre
la tabla y el hielo sobre el cual está
colocado la tabla así que aquí dicen no
hay fricción entre la tabla y el hielo
el auto de control remoto se enciende y
luego se apaga cual es la posible
posición final del auto y la tabla ahora
ya que el auto está en reposo y la tabla
también está en reposo eso significa que
el centro de masa en este sistema está
también en reposo y ya
que no hay ninguna fuerza neta externa
el sistema el centro de masa tendrá que
permanecer en el mismo sitio bien la
masa del auto está justo en el valor de
3 y si observas el centro de esta tabla
está en el valor de 5 por lo tanto el
centro de masa está aquí en el valor de
4 aquí tenemos a nuestro centro de masa
y ahora lo que vamos a buscar es cuál de
todos estos diagramas que tenemos aquí
tienen su centro de masa igual en el
valor de 4 así que vamos a verlo vamos a
ver primero la opción a aquí el auto
está en el valor de 3 y si observas el
centro de la tabla también está en el
valor de 3 por lo tanto aquí tenemos el
centro de masa de la opción am y eso
quiere decir que esto no puede estar
correcto ya que el centro de masa no se
puede mover eso porque no hubo fuerzas
externas en nuestro sistema entonces el
centro de masa que comenzó en reposo
aquí
tiene que mantenerse en reposo ok vamos
a ver qué es lo que pasa ahora con el
inciso b se observa en el inciso b
tenemos al autor en cuatro y al centro
de la tabla en tres lo que me da un
valor justo aquí del centro de masa pero
otra vez no estamos en cuatro por lo
tanto no es la opción bien así que vamos
a revisar qué es lo que pasa con la
opción sem tenemos al autor en el valor
de seis y al centro de la tabla en el
valor de cuatro lo que me da un centro
de masa aquí en el valor de cinco pero
de nuevo no estamos en cuatro así que no
es la opción ser y vamos a ver por
último la opción de se observa el autor
está en cinco muy bien y el centro de la
tabla está en tres lo que me da un
centro de masa en cuatro que es justo lo
que estábamos buscando así que mi opción
correcta es
de lujo